hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the amnesia
custom story the great work now I tried
to load this up before that's why
there's a continue thing there but I
forgot that I wasn't recording so whoops
alright so this is a custom story that
has new monsters new music new textures
basically it's got new stuff and I'm
very excited for that because I love it
when an amnesia comes some story really
goes the extra mile to put out something
new I mean mostly amnesia custom stories
that I've been playing it's getting kind
of stale because there's the same thing
over and over again but I'm really eager
to give this try so here we go
the great work I Damascus you are
Charles long didn't an archaeologists
studying mini burg a German Castle
abandoned due to recent cave-ins you are
sleeping late one morning when you are
shaken awake by a tremor running through
the castle there is no sign of your
partner Jane where has she gone
last time I heard it I thought of Corey
I made a joke about Jane oh yeah is it
just fine okay alright so I did not get
far before I realized oh no Charles or
2aq I'm anxious to start digging but the
Sun isn't up yet no no no cool spear my
word yeah a bit we can discuss our
findings at lunch
most excellent yes my name is Charles
Charles Charles Xavier no Charlie long
okay so I don't know how many chapters
are but apparently there are more than
six and if that's anything to go by I
don't know who's gonna be as epically
long it's like the things of the night
but I have a feeling this is gonna be a
good one and if it's got new stuff I am
all the more excited about going through
it because oh this could be a good one
okay so um Jane and I arrived in
Middleburg Castle this morning most of
the western wing was completely
collapsed and the rest of the castle
show sign of dangerous instability was
wives of the outbreak family to leave in
a hurry
okay causes unclear castle solidly built
there's some instability below the
castle excavated the structure before
never exclude wealth event
knowledge okay so that's as far as I got
and I don't want to spend too much time
reading the notes unless I feel it's
very important but for now
um it's not all that bad can't see a
bloody thing oh wait it was touching huh
oh no wait don't any it's fun it's just
booze latch is jammed or we got Jane's
door is damaged something heavy might
finish a trick ah some hell you say how
about do you wait what are you blocking
so something in here that I should know
about
hellowho tinderbox yes almost mr. come
in with me I said you're coming with me
jeez ha suck on that
I said sorrow that it's heavy but should
be thrown you call me a [ __ ] wha you
call mrs. a widget ah sorry I got a
little upset all right so I just bashed
my way into Jane's room for no reason
okay storage key tender box storage
tender box okay day two Charles eye for
detail is proving a great access well
thank you baby
okay professor ah mention tunnels below
the castle they don't appear to be
sealed in a manner to keep someone out
but to keep something inside so there's
something underneath the castle that
they don't want to get out but we're
digging right in cuz we're smart smart
smart okay something that they feared
either way Tommy's running out the
gadigal castle won't be standing much
longer Jane
whittler why'd you go down if you knew
there was danger you should have waited
for me or not um you're a strong
independent woman who don't need no man
obviously okay so
that was that see won't budge will it
budge for a key can I use his item his
way okay
no but Joan Oba hello hello tinderboxes
anything anything useful anything at all
yes absolutely nothing and nope I am
wasting my time
that is definitely new music by the way
I've never heard that music before an
amnesia so I am very happy about that
one the hell hey what that ah
oh this gah bah okay here we go
got it ooh something here lantern a good
da gotta hear how some of these things
just don't open correctly like they
don't know it's good for them teach
settle some died okay so oh hello old
place is gonna come down alright so this
is about the limit of how far I've
gotten well I was out actually my limit
of how far I've gotten was out the front
door what am I looking at well was that
door it's locked
good thing I have this key AHA so ooh
whoa whoa I wandered into some place
Asha oh hello
loud down dumb I am in some place where
I should not be that is also news music
I've never heard that before right
Oh some behind you obviously come on
come on oh god you're heavy
but I'm so strong I can't even throw a
box hard I don't think I can move this
okay what is behind you what secrets do
you hold ah what is this
okay there's some sort of door behind
here um oh wait hang on give me out give
me a command so this is a bookshelf
there probably a book I need to pull
hang on let me get out of my freaking
way
you know you nope okay yeah no book
hi okay though it would have been too
obvious oh it's behind here you're
hiding something I know you're hiding
something
are you hiding nothing Oh laughs ah ah
yeah I am so smart hey and I kind of
want that I got I went through that too
fast hey let me go back out I know that
there was my partner looked up here for
some reason is there some reason that
did that do I need something from up
there I think there's a way to climb up
there
um they throw somehow all right let's
just move forward if I need to backtrack
I will see yep yep know how god I've
created an obstacle for myself come on
come on yeah okay yep in here did Jane
come this way how did Jane get this way
oh no way for her to put the boxes back
up there and it's also still really
hello who's down there
okay there's no way that Jane could have
put the box back I'm gonna throw this
down first huh I didn't hear a sound
where did it go ow
my knees Oh knowledge was something that
had to be spread to everyone hartleb
hope one day to gain full comprehension
of the divine order of things an idea of
calm many Asst that he would followed
avidly Mauryan though suggested that it
could be taken a step further the humans
were capable of gaining godlike
omniscience
okie-dokie uh it's hard to see I really
wish I had a lantern because they kill
hello okay then ha ha ha this must be
the tunnels underneath the city then
what the hell is that
Oh Len there are definitely our new
sounds in this Oh Oh ed I got a smile on
my face because I'm really excited
because I I mean I love him easy to
death and uh I haven't
there hasn't been like a new experience
for you know the the game that I really
really loved in a while and a movement
tinderbox
oh man oh I'm so excited I hope this
does last a while because this could be
the next great amnesia custom story and
I'd be so happy for that okay Jill 24th
of July 1651 I was so close so close to
the perfect alchemy I managed to save
one shard before I had to flee but the
rest may be lost I don't know what has
become a hard lip but I fear the worst I
can only hope that I am safe here Ernst
owes me for his daughter but it was
still difficult to convince him to build
tunnels underneath the castle I have
promised not to disturb them and work in
peace I don't know what it was that
attacked us in England and I don't know
if it's going to come after me here
the defense is that I've built that I've
had built here will only protect me for
so much J Maureen okay so this is a
blast from the past
but I do not have a lantern still in the
hell's my Lantern Jane where the hell
did you put my lantern where oh right
there gay wait what am I looking at
another boy am I looking at
oh oh oh no oh oh poor Jane was my note
what was Jana you don't even care that
Jane was just crushed by a giant pile of
rocks what was Jay looking for down here
I don't know a way out a way to survive
maybe you're such a dick Charles Charles
they mean to cure us
but I say we are the cue ready we are
the cure
I can't get in there hello I who's here
huh
fish whoa what hey let me try that again
rip aah possessed it's a demon demon
debe demon flowerbed
what uh what I've done Oh what is going
on there that's horrifying whatever is
happening there is so okay what again
loud down it what's this chunk of
crystallized potage what the hell is
potage all right I do not have a lot of
oil I'm gonna run out in two seconds if
I'm not careful with it
all right
I didn't see anything else in there
besides it when ou finds scare me for
saying there um see what's here first
yeah so I thought another room anything
here a value oil oil please tell me
there's oil I'm gonna run out of oil
like in two seconds that's not fair I
just got this lantern you can't take it
away from me that soon please don't
please let me light some stuff up uh
helps a little bit at least those
torches did something okay so what do we
got here a big gate Oh lever her yeah
the machinery is not working right then
it is dark in here
that's carry on oil oil please oil
anything anything oil please I'm a
hunter
you can't let me run out of oil I just
got it I got no oh
jump-scare glass jar jump-scare room
dumpster no it's over here end of the
line man why did Jane go off alone I
really wouldn't have preferred to not be
down here oh hello oil of vitriol full
of an acidic liquid okay so that could
be used to burn through something or
other
all right potentially very useful okay
so carrying on let's see what's over
here
in the darkness
hello I did I just go this way or is
this a new way yeah there's a new way do
one of them new monsters oh man oh my
heart oh I've been sincerely terrified
of a monster named Neil a long time oh
oh well thank you what to tell yourself
something just fell from my ceiling I
don't know what it was oh man oh man
hi guys I got a big old smile on my face
because I'm really happy I'm really
happy I couldn't even explain to you
exactly why I'm happy but I am I am
always gonna be a good story oh this is
gonna be a good story II
I was so excited okay whoo hello levar
its rusted in place how about some
acidic oil up in this [ __ ] can I use
this item this way all right well I
tried I've learned a long time ago in my
amnesia adventures that you need to try
everything on everything all the time or
else you will be stuck in nowhere land
and in nowhere land you would remain
until you die okay so I don't see
anything in here that put some
underneath all this machinery I've been
wasting oil can I move these anything
that's movable I'm assuming that there's
something hiding there but a lot of this
is not movable okay so probably need to
go get something from something else
before I can come in here but that will
have to wait since I am all out of time
so oh I'm so excited I'm so happy that
there's something new and interesting
that comes amnesia I mean before a
museum machine for pigs gets release of
course though thank you all so much for
watching let me know what you think of
this custom story in the description
below the link to the custom story is
also the description as with everything
else so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye